a las vegas company hoping to be part of
the transformation of transportation in
the valley we're talking about
captain they unveiled their new
operations to become the largest
privately owned
local electric vehicle fleet christian
kosovos is in southern highlands
with how you can benefit from it
electric cars are definitely the way of
the future according to las vegas
company
captain they want to enhance the
experience of both the tourist
and the local by getting you around town
in one of these
the company currently has 100 vehicles
of tesla's model
s and x and they have plans on growing
that fleet
by 10 vehicles per week the operation
allows a user to book an electric
vehicle with the driver
which provides an enhanced ride while
running with the most advanced air
filtration system
the fleet is currently staged at
terminal one and three at mccarran
airport
as well as locations on and off the
strip like bellagio cosmopolitan
and the red rock casino rates are
governed by the nevada transportation
authority
and will set you back between 42 and 55
dollars
captain ceo andrew meyer says he is
looking to hire drivers
and expand their current 175 full-time
staff
our mission by employing full-time
drivers
and bringing in these new sustainable
premium electric vehicles
we think the combination of those two
creates more of a customer experience
elevation and
what better market to launch and be
headquartered than las vegas these
electric vehicles are currently
available around the valley there are
future plans for captain to expand to
southern california and florida
i have more information on
eightnewsnow.com on how to book
one of your rides in southern highlands
christian casadas 8 news now